[Music]
welcome to our program i'd like to know
i'm daniel miranda associate speaker of
secrets and seal and i'm in the company
of pastor c.a murray also a colleague
here an associate speaker for this
channel welcome pastor murray good to be
here with you daniel and also we want to
welcome you thank you for joining us
thank you for sending your questions
we would not have this program if it
weren't for your questions so we
appreciate participating in that
if you want to continue sending
questions or want to know how to
participate
you can send your questions to the
following email address that's tv at
some tv.org again tv at some tv
dot org
we have uh
a lot of questions so if you don't find
an answer to your question soon just be
patient and we will get to your question
once it is the turn
today we will continue with the
questions from brother victor
he sent us four questions and we were
able to answer only two
but before we do that uh let's begin
with the word of prayer can you
pastor ca pray for us be glad to do so
father god
again we praise you and thank you for
your word which lightens the path before
us and shines before us even as a
brighter day so father we ask you now to
bless our heart give us the mind of
christ under the spirit
of christ
because we know that spiritual things
are spiritually discerned
may we have the discernment of christ
may we have spiritual eyesight to see
the truths that are
lie
lying in the
the word of god and that can be
unearthed so easily to the benefit of
all bless us just father be the center
and circumference of all that we do and
say so that christ is seen and glorified
and again we thank you in jesus name
amen amen amen
very good so um
let's go to the third question from
brother victor
third question says that this is a very
very
good question
it says i believe that the holy spirit
is the third person of the godhead
no doubt at all
my question though is why even before
creation
the creation of the world lucifer had a
problem with the position of jesus
christ and never the position of the
holy spirit
how do we rationalize the presence of
the holy spirit
with quotes such as this one in
patriarchs and prophets
quote sin originated with him who next
to christ
had been most honor of god and was
highest in power and glory among the
inhabitants of heaven
if satan was the most honored next to
christ
then
where was the holy spirit
that's that's a good question i've never
quite asked myself in that particular
way
uh because we know in ezekiel 28 that he
was the one of the the covering cherubs
he was in the presence and i see that
next to uh as much
uh as presence as as as much as position
although there is some positioning there
he is uh next to god in the presence of
the lord
and um
on the other side
uh was uh an individual with whom he had
he had problems right uh because he was
in the presence so
obviously he could not well he wanted to
be god but he wanted to have the
the power of god
uh that wasn't possible but evidently
there was an intimacy
a demonstrated intimacy between christ
and his father that satan coveted uh in
the position but not having the position
and that's what he wanted
the holy spirit uh was not
um
how can i say it
was not in the equation it was the
position between christ and his father
that satan uh could not abide in and
that seemed to wrangle him and caused
occasion the jealousy that uh
we we see as resulting in sin right
you know what we need to understand when
we study the godhead is that yes we
believe
god the father god the son god the holy
spirit are three distinct persons
[Music]
eternal beings
god is god for the father is god the son
is god the holy spirit is god
but
when we come to
certain differences like this what we
need to understand is the roles of each
member of the godhead yes very much
and the role of the holy spirit has
always been behind the scenes
actually when we come to john chapter 15
let me see if this is the one i am
looking for
john chapter
15 yes verse
26 john 15 26
uh the bible says i'm reading from the
new king james version it says but when
the helper comes or the comforter the
paracletus
whom i shall send to you from the father
the spirit of truth who proceeds from
the father
he will testify
of me
so
jesus
uh role is to exalt the father jesus
testifies of the father
the holy spirit testifies of jesus
so
that is why that for me would be a
simple explanation
we don't see
the holy spirit when it when when when
we see
god the father and god the son on the
throne
because the holy spirit's work is always
behind the scene he's actually down here
yes on earth with us
with his people you know in creation we
see the holy spirit on earth he was
hovering over the earth
and there are some quotes actually
that suggests
and some people have come to this
conclusion that um gabriel
is the same holy spirit
because um he took the place of satan
and
satan was the next to christ and some
people ask well if satan was next to
christ
where's the holy spirit yeah
yes you know
i i like your your your understanding
and i i don't know precisely the
chronology of how
the creation experience wasn't unfolded
to the heavenly intelligences because we
pick up the
the the thought almost in mid-sentence
or in mid-thought right the bible begins
with barashith elohim
elohim always get them twisted
let us make man you know so
obviously there was some discussion as
to whether
given the fact that uh there was some
disturbance in heaven anyway
should we go ahead and do this
yes
genesis 1 1 let us let us let us go
ahead and do this um
so uh satan wasn't part of that now it
was also indicated at that time that
that
once man
was created
that really the
for the most part
the connection between earth and heaven
was going to be through jesus
that that when it talks about god in the
old testament we're talking about the
glorified
lord uh who was there and spoke to moses
at the bush and yeah and uh who who
walked with adam and eve so we're
talking about christ so it
that occasioned part of satan's problem
right
the holy spirit was not
simply was not there at that point doing
those kinds of things he is as you well
said behind the scenes
uh the the the initiator was god the
actuator was jesus christ right and it
was that that wrankled satan and
occasioned his jealousy of the son of
god yeah he he has special issues with
the son yes and that's why there is
emphasis on the sun yes now in the holy
spirit he wasn't covering a position
behind the scenes he was covering
coveting the position
that was uh more exalted that was more
popular right which was the position of
jesus christ yeah he was the covenant
being a cameraman yes he wanted to be in
front of the camera that's right
[Laughter]
oh well said yes
very good okay
all righty uh question number four and
and victor we we we we are you've got
you got two shows man so far a show and
a half four good questions they're
they're the product of thought uh he is
from nairobi i've been in the city of
nairobi uh wonderful christians in in
nairobi uh growing church in in kenya
and uh thank you victor for uh sending
in these questions the last the fourth
and last
after the third coming of jesus
since the world will have been utterly
destroyed at his second coming
is it fair to expect that it will take a
long time probably a number of years
between the third coming
and the destruction of the wicked
the reasoning here is based on the fact
that the wicked will need
will need to re-engineer weapons of
destruction
which will
need industries of sorts and marshes
themselves into armies before they
attacked the saints
how long would you say it would take and
what will the saints be doing during
this time
again another he thinks you know it's an
interesting interesting question
uh
what's safety i i got something going on
in my head here but right but yeah well
it is obvious the first time i read uh
the
last chapter of the great controversy
that i read about the wicked they had
weapons and
things like that i said well this is
this is going to take some time for them
to build up all that
now as to how long
would that take well the bible doesn't
give us that yeah that time
i know
there is someone who is very well known
i'm not going to say the name
but uh
i think this i don't know brother victor
is connecting the first question and the
fourth question
because i heard someone based on the
first question the 7 thousand years or
the six thousand years yes uh using a
quote of all the ninety quotes of ellen
white about that that topic
using one of them
where she
apparently
suggests
that they're about to be fulfilled
so he was breaking up that period
between
uh before
the second coming and after the second
coming you know in other words
the seventh thousand or the six thousand
years of sin will be fulfilled in that
short period of time of this controversy
when satan is going to gather of the
host
now i don't know how he did that but uh
that's kind of like some gymnastics yeah
i have to go to work forward yes
gymnastics and um
you know we need to be careful not to do
that with that with the word of god
trying to accommodate it in ways that
may sound logic to me yes
now i am not saying that this question
is coming from from that position but it
sounds to me
but anyways
whether it is coming from that from that
or not
something is clear yes it's going to
take some time
but we don't know how long and what what
will the saints be doing inside the city
all they will be with god worshiping
and uh and uh beholding the judgment of
the nations
a couple of things and i like where
you're going with this um what will the
saints be doing one of the things they
won't be doing is preparing for battle
uh because
uh christ is going to end this exactly
so we will not be spending time and i
say we i'm presuming
we will not be spending time forging
weapons of war defense of our offensive
because at this point the battle is not
ours exactly our our warfare has ceased
we are saved so no more battle for us
what christ is going to do now
is dispatch sin and sinners so um
we'll be caring about our normal
activities because the city will not be
taken so there's no
there's no doubt in our mind what's
going to happen so if if you're not
really in any danger then you don't need
to prepare yourself so that's one two
we have quotes in
great controversy that
these men of war will come up with the
same mindsets
that they went down when i look at the
destruction of the earth during christ's
second coming of course the hills and
mountains are overthrown and everything
is
the the destruction really has
more to do with the destruction of of
people who are not saved and wicked
people now the earth is going to be
flipped over but it doesn't mean that
guns and rifles and bullets and those
things are not lying around to be picked
up and used again we know that there's
no humanity
alive but uh the the the precise
condition of the world
um
we know it's gonna be in in chaos but
there may be still things around yeah
that that that that can be used right
so i don't think i don't see the time as
being an extended period of time i think
we are
really in the halls of speculation when
we try to do that because the bible
gives no indication that i can recall
about that having said that uh since
their mind is already made for war
uh satan has just got to whip them up uh
get them into a frenzy and they attack
we don't know the sophistication of the
equipment uh it could be just guns it
could be clubs it could be
knives it could be spears it could be
anything that's lying around around you
know um that can be converted into a
weapon so we don't know if they're going
to go back and get
stinger missiles and you know and
submarines and and other kinds of things
tanks and those kind of things or just
crude weapons to attack the city right
suffice to just say whatever they have
it's not going to work
and uh so it doesn't really matter how
much time but once this final battle is
done sin and sinners will be no more yes
ever amen that's what we're looking
forward to praise the lord amen
okay
so we have uh
our next question here from brother
patrick
and you know this is the first time i
hear this question
some people are saying that satan is
still going to heaven to be in front of
god's presence
they are basing this claim on ephesians
6 11 and 12.
what's your view on this
it'll be good to read this first
before we answer the question can you
please rate that for us pastor ca i'm
turning to ephesians
even as we speak
and should have been there air now
but i am armor of god that is the
context
[Laughter]
ephesians chapter 6 and i'm in verses 11
and 12 right reading from the new king
james
picking it up at verse 11 put on the
whole armor of god
that you may be able to stand against
the wiles of the devil for you do not
wrestle against flesh and blood but
against principalities and powers
comma against the rulers of the darkness
of this age comma
against spiritual hosts of wickedness in
heavenly places
i was struggling with the question
trying to understand the rationale
behind the question
i don't know how someone would use this
tech this text to say that satan is
going to heaven
first of all the text is not talking
about that at all he's talking about the
spiritual warfare that we as questions
go through right now
it is true that these principalities and
powers and these are satan and the
demons
okay
i don't know if the person
is uh picking on that phrase on heavenly
places
referring
to satan having placed but even
if satan is still going to go to heaven
i would assume that that were true
is
after the thousand years when sin will
be eradicated so what is the point of
satan going to heaven and continue war
further
if he had been saved
so
this text definitely is not talking
about that i think that was a big twist
on the text yeah
to to to to try to to to make this speak
of heavenly places you've got to do a
little dancing yeah um and and this is
not what it's it's it's saying
number one just to try to break it down
um
and the reason i put those commas there
is because he is he's explaining himself
uh put on the whole armor of god
so we understand so we can fight against
the walls of the devil for we do not
wrestle against flesh and blood
but against principalities and powers
rulers of the darkness of this age
so we're dealing with the rulers of the
darkness of this age that's right that's
a husky
different thought
against spiritual host of wickedness in
heavenly places now if he was talking
about heaven he wouldn't say heavenly
places he'd say in heaven
so we're talking about heavenly places
now the greek for heavenly places is epi
episode
anytime you're dealing with epi you're
dealing with buff like epidermis for
skin and right epi and asusia really
means
above the sky right so
what he's he's trying to identify is
you're dealing with a spiritual realm
and i like what the
the um
amplified bible says here it says
that we're dealing with
supernatural
beings
uh
so he he's saying one you're dealing
with
spiritual wickedness on the earth but
you're also dealing with supernatural
spiritual beings so he's saying put on
the whole armor of god because you're
fighting on two fronts right you've got
wickedness that you can see touch feel
you've got wicked people people who are
led by the devil then you've also got
spiritual battles that are going on
in in the supernatural realm not in
heaven but in the supernatural realm the
metaphysical realm the realm you cannot
see so he's trying to prepare you uh and
and the word um epi usia is is uh is a
plural word in the greek it is it is
neuter neutral case it's in the dative
case so we we see that it's um it's not
talking about heaven per se it's talking
about the heavens or the spiritual realm
right yeah and i like that you emphasize
of this age
so this is talking about the present
today this is not talking about the
future or a time when satan is going to
be in the presence of god yes very good
uh could you read our next question
pastor ca is this one from claudius
claudius yes
and i suspect he is from the great
continent of africa although it does not
say i would say
central east africa
i'd like to hear um
hello pastor miranda and murray i was
watching the program i'd like to know
and
pastor bohr read this paragraph
from heavenly places
page 151
let bats be taken
shoes be blacked and clothing be put in
readiness
does this mean we are not to take a
shower on the sabbath
[Laughter]
if if it does then i have sinned greatly
so have i
i remember preaching in philippines
several years ago i showered in the
morning i shouted after church i shouted
after the evening meeting i shot again
when i got back to the hotel at night i
was three showers on sabbath um
one of the reasons that this this
council was given was of the kinds of
work it it took to to get a bath
prepared back in illinois today
today you want a bathroom you change
your clothes you jump in the shower you
come out you dry off you're done right
back then you had to collect wood you
had to start a fire you had to put it in
a container you had to gather it
it was a it was a labor-intensive
activity
that really would con consume a lot of
time and a lot of effort
if it were done on the sabbath so this
this thing about clothes being in
readiness
my sabbath clothes are already they're
in the closet hanging out my suits are
there
the kind of labor it takes to prepare
for sabbath these days is not the kind
of labor it took to prepare for sabbath
in those days so she's she's she's
countenancing against
the heavy kinds of work that would have
to be done to be ready for sabbath if
you delayed that work until the coming
of the sabbath exactly and the principle
behind it is
doing things that would destroy
the spirit of the sabbath yes and
definitely going to the woods yeah
bringing wood
uh starting a fire warming up the water
and all that that definitely takes a lot
of work and
and uh sabbath can become stressful
doing that yes but today yeah it's not
the same it's not the same
oh it's not the same you know i'm
thinking about that that council that
she gave about the bicycle back then
they had the bicycle with the one huge
wheel in the front a little in the back
and she she talks about bicycles well i
i remember years ago an adventists who
really when they got baptized tossed out
their bicycle and all the kids bicycles
um because they said ny says we
shouldn't have bicycles but you you've
got to put the the
statement in context exactly
um
those bicycles were very exotic and very
expensive
and she was saying
don't
throw out your budget throw out your
money
bankrupt yourself trying to get
something that's fashionably hit at this
particular point in time it's not an
invading against bicycles per se it's
against spending the kind of money that
you'd have to spend to own something
that's new and now it's like her saying
well don't don't buy a mercedes benz uh
well if you can afford one fine
but if you're like me you're kind of a
volkswagen kind of guy you know you
don't ever say this money or buy a
volkswagen right because she also says
buy the best that you can afford right
but don't
bankrupt yourself buying something that
is unnecessary right
so
a counsel here that is very pertinent is
that when we read the spirit of prophecy
like the bible we need to extract the
principle yes and see why she gave that
council in what circumstances they
should give the council yes how can we
extract the principle what is the
principle behind the council
how can we apply that principle today
yes because we cannot go to the letter
and apply
to the letter what she had said or else
we would fall into interesting yes uh
practices today indeed
you apply the same counsel the the same
studies to her that you would to the
bible you asked some questions who said
it
what did they say
what did they mean
what did the people that they were
speaking to understand it to mean and
then you make application you've got to
do all five of those things before you
can assure yourself that your answer is
correct and applicable to the to the
scripture and to the spirit of prophecy
amen
we've got a second question by brother
claudius
um
my second question comes from hebrews
chapter 12
chapter 2 rather i'm sorry
14 and 15. what does it mean
that the devil had power over death and
how and where we
live life time
how we live
time bondage shine bondage to the fear
of death right okay so he's quoting from
the from the actual text yeah
we should read that right hebrews 2
verses 14 and 15
the bible says in as much then as the
children have partaken of flesh and
blood he himself likewise shared the
same that through death he might destroy
him who had the power power of death
that is the devil and released those who
through fear of death were all their
lifetime subject
to bondage so the question is
how is it that the devil had the power
over death well
for me it means and um and i believe
that's what the text is saying that
having the power of her death is since
he is the author of sin
which at the same time brings death he
claims the death as his own yes in jude
verse 9 we see that he was contending
for the body of moses
because he was claiming moses as his own
he had made
moses fallen into temptation and when
jesus came to resurrect him he was
saying no he's mine
he fall under my power the power of sin
and therefore death so i believe in that
sense but it doesn't mean that he is the
one that controls death or he in the
underworld and and he has the power of
the of the death in the underworld
[Music]
i agree with you and um i
i come to the same answer from a
slightly different text i took james
chapter 1 verse 15. uh satan is the
author of sin and sin when it matures
brings death that's right so then he can
be
responsible for death um christ said in
john chapter 14 verse 30 uh the prince
of this world comes he has nothing in me
so we know that these things um
christ comes to give us life
satan is the author of death he is a
liar and a murderer from the beginning
he is the father of death the author of
death um
from john 8 44. so
as he now
convicts the world of sin and
moves the world into sin and the result
of sin is death then you've got to lay
it at satan's feet but
we have the promise that one day death
will be eradicated sin will be
eradicated sinners will be eradicated
and death will be
no more amen now in regards to what does
it mean that we are
we live with fear fear of death
well human beings were not created to
die
so death brings fear to those who are
not in christ
but christ brings hope the hope of
eternal life yes one of the greatest
fears i'm looking at the clock
for many people who don't understand
about death is is the fear of death are
men who are very afraid to die because
they don't understand it well our time
has fast slipped into eternity allow me
in closing to wish you both grace and
peace through our lord and savior jesus
christ we'll see you again soon bye bye
and god bless
[Music]
you